welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Joker released one final
trailer to creep us out with Joaquin
Phoenix's method that is I guess method
in the madness this portrayal of Arthur
Fleck the man who becomes the Joker
apparently as some kind of revenge for
getting trolled on a late-night show I
mean just imagine all the psychos Jimmy
Fallon is inspiring as we talked and
just kidding no one lasts as maniacally
as he does I'm gonna break down this
trailer shot four shots for all the
interesting details that you might have
overlooked and spoiler warning to kiss
send me my predictions in the beam right
and thanks to privacy calm for sponsor
in this breakdown more details later on
how they can help protect your online
spending let's get started
[Music]
please stop bothering like him sure
okay the trailer opens on Arthur's
commute into the Gotham inner city the
imagery here suggests a class divided
the set in the year 1981 a year when the
US was reeling from an economic
recession and the decay of urban life in
cities like New York which Gotham is
based on Arthur makes this kid giggle
and make it silly faces but as any
single adult male who looks like Arthur
Fleck can attest society definitely has
a limit on how long strangers are okay
with you playing with their kids I like
the detail that even after the mother
snaps at Arthur mid silly face he tries
to drop his expression but his distorted
smile remains locked in as if the guy's
not in control of his own facial muscles
it's a subtle symptom of his own mental
health problems and on to less subtle
symptoms right there I have some bad
news for you this is the last time we'll
be meeting you don't listen dear okay
next
Arthur tears up his clown shoes based on
the bruising on his back I think this is
after he gets jumped in the alley maybe
he's trying to fix his shoes like loosen
them so he doesn't run as awkwardly in
them because in that neighborhood you're
probably gonna have to run a lot or
maybe he's sneaky like razor blades into
his shoes not only would sneaky clown
prank style weapons be a total joker
move but also kind of parallel Travis
bickel's hidden weapon building and taxi
driver one of the two Martin Scorsese
Robert De Niro films that are big
influences on this film Arthur lets out
a maniacal laugh which apparently
Joaquin Phoenix developed by watching
videos of patients suffering from
pathological laughter a real
neurological disorder that makes people
laugh uncontrollably maybe someone
should look into Jimmy Fallon this
location appears to be haha' talent
booking the location scene early set
photos with Glenn flesh lers rival clown
character visible in the background here
the halls are lined with circus clown
props
perhaps Arthur works a stay job for like
a clown event business entertaining sick
kids and hospitals doing some street
marketing but he can later use these
same clown props for his new movement on
to the next section
it is as every week how's your job are
you having any negative thoughts all I
have are negative thoughts
okay just one thing to point out here is
Arthur stands shirtless at the sink if
you listen closely there's an
interesting sound mixed in it's almost
like a squeegee wiper run instrumental
strings being scratched it just creates
this unnerving expression of Arthur's
fragile mental state next clip here
Arthur sits with his ailing mother penny
in a hospital room and sees Murray
Franklin Robert DeNiro's talk show host
character Murray Franklin was inspired
by De Niro's character in another
Scorsese film the king of comedy about
an unstable struggling comedian
violently forces himself into a guest
spot on a late-night show obviously
another major parallel for this Joker
story now Murray's shown a clip of
Arthur at pogos comedy club Arthur's
backstory here is a nod to the tragic
Joker origin presented in The Killing
Joke graphic novel but if you think
about it this clip that Murray's showing
wouldn't be like a viral YouTube clip
because this is in 1981 so this was the
Arthur's submission video to the show
and they're using it on the show to
humiliate him
that's pretty effed up it'd be like this
channel showing my audition video back
in 2015 when I initially didn't get this
job and use it to make fun of me you
know actually that would have been great
exposure next
[Music]
so Hospital is it
here there are some shots of the clown
riding that's happening around Gotham it
appears to some murders public minima
Arthur are inspiring destabilization of
fraught economic conditions and class
warfare but the wealthy elite like
Thomas Wayne right in the crosshairs of
it now there's actually another detail
to point out here but before we get to
that thank you to privacy comm for
sponsoring this breakdown privacy calm
is a free service that lets you buy
things online using virtual cards
instead of real ones protecting your
identity and bank information on the
Internet
it's essentially a digital burner card
so you don't have to use your real card
number which I'm sorry two reports I and
many others have had stolen and needs to
purchase things and places I've never
been before like I didn't buy weird sex
toys in k-town I get those in the valley
you shouldn't have to hand over the keys
to your finances every time you buy
something nor should you have to worry
about getting double charged for one of
your millions of content subscriptions
so for example I have set up an account
with privacy linked to my bank account
and I'm creating a named one time car to
pay for a mutant bread subscription I'm
gonna set the limit of this card for $1
so I could just try out YouTube's bread
for free for a month so when I set up
this subscription will use this dummy
credit card numbers at privacy
auto-generated later like let's say I
forget to cancel the subscription if I
don't want it any more I will get
notified when privacy blocks YouTube
from charging me the full amount for the
next month because this burner cards $1
limit was maxed out safe and you know
what this works for anything it's so
easy and again it's free and we're
actually gonna make this deal even
better for you guys first time customers
you sign up with privacy calm slash new
rock stars will get 5 dollars off their
first purchase with privacy calm just go
to privacy calm slash new rock stars
that's PR IVAC why.com slash any wroc k
st ARS to get five dollars off your
first purchase now ok back to the
trailer there's a sign on the news that
reads we are all clowns evoking a
possible Joker cult that's forming here
perhaps one who's street violence might
be what forces Murray Abrams hand to let
Arthur appear on his TV show then Arthur
smokes while painting his face white and
based on that brush I don't think that
clown face paint it looks like wall
paint or primer it's just not something
to use on your face or your tongue
Arthur's vacant expression here reminds
me of Buffalo Bills makeup montage and
the sounds of the lamps I can't wait for
the match up videos putting this clip to
goodbye horses next
if I even really existed
I do
starting here Arthur reacts to a Grimm
newspaper front page latest news on the
murders with a killer freaking clown
image clearly Arthur is thrilled to see
his movement catching fire there's a
shot of Wayne Hall with a Charlie
Chaplin modern times exhibit now modern
times is a classic film that centers
around the [ __ ] Chaplin's tragic clown
persona who is similarly stuck in a
soul-sucking job suffering a mental
breakdown inciting class revolts and
falling in love let's move on I think
this is funny
just a joke to you
okay Arthur plants one on Sophie that's
AC beats character and then smashes his
face against a metal grate probably
snatched in a medical file away from
Brian Tyree Henry's character at Arkham
state hospital
perhaps Arthur's trying to get his
mother's medical records maybe his own
to prevent criminal record linking to
his mental health file Arthur takes a
punch from Thomas Wayne who is
unknowingly creating the villain who
will consume his city and later his son
Arthur also appears in the back of a cop
car as it gets smashed by an ambulance
perhaps his Joker cult has taken over
the city to come break him free from
custody next clip one small thing yeah
will you bring me out can you introduce
me as Joker
[Music]
okay so there's Marie and Marc Maron's
talent Booker character they seem
reluctant to host Arthur here again
probably worried about playing into his
demands and give him his moniker on such
a public stage and then a quick shot
reveals Arthur stomping on someone in an
alley you can actually see the victim's
leg move in there reminder that this
Joker films room rated R for a quote
strong bloody violence disturbing
behavior language and brief sexual
images hopefully brief is the short word
there I don't see what's under this tidy
whities yeah before we move on there's a
quick shot of some writing going on
outside of a movie theater in who is
that coming through the door there that
is Thomas Wayne with his son Bruce saw
him in the other trailer and Thomas his
wife Martha yes we might seriously be
looking at yet another murder depiction
of the Wayne's and I think that is
Arthur running up in the middle there to
intercept them with what looks like a
lead pipe or maybe a cane rumor has it
is that people who are familiar with the
plot of this story say that it might
alienate some hardcore DC fans and I
think one possible way that they could
do that would be by retconning Batman's
origin the same way Tim Burton Rhett
Condit by having Joker kill Thomas and
Martha Wayne instead of Joe Chill as he
is in the traditional backstory also is
Martha wearing pearls she better be the
imagery of those things just bouncing on
the ground it's just too dramatic and on
to the final clip
the cloud
okay the music here is send in the
clowns a song Stephen Sondheim wrote for
its musical A Little Night Music it's
all about the dejection and foolishness
felt by live entertainers and Arthur's
doing this weird little dance before the
curtains rise similar to his dance that
he does in the bathroom and the other
footage and similar to a dance that
Murray does this dance could be like
another aspect of his mania physical
tick that he learned from his idol but
then he does to remind himself it's all
a show and as if his cynicism wasn't
already clear enough this dude is
smoking when he goes out into the lights
this guest spot is not for him to get
laughs its to declare his nihilistic
vision to the world is this Joker enough
of a DC film for you or do you prefer it
only being loosely fanatically connected
to the DC world comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram
twitter eddie gave us subscribing to
rock stars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thank you for
joining me and let's see some arthur
flick buffalo bill action
[Music]